[Music]
everybody is Charlie we got a whole
bunch of news about the Avengers 4
trailer as well as an official Marvel
Cinematic Universe timeline Kevin Feige
was teasing they would reveal an
official one just because of all the
continuity problems with spider-man
homecoming well now we finally have it
so I'll break that down but I'll talk
about the Avengers force stuff first
there's a new round of that imax ticket
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a Marvel
related comments on the video I'll name
a new winner at the end of this I'll be
getting a whole lot of questions about
when the Avengers 4 trailer is dropping
because there were a bunch of rumors
earlier this week people saying that it
might drop on Black Friday because
people have done that in the past there
was a lot of Star Wars stuff that
happened around the force awakens a
couple years ago but it seems like
what's really going on is is that Marvel
isn't really doing anything special this
week there were a whole bunch of
infinity war Avengers related
announcements recently like Netflix said
that they're going to be getting
infinity war December 25th Christmas so
if you're on break from work school
whatever during the Christmas holiday
you'll be able to watch infinity war as
many times as you want back-to-back on
Netflix we're still supposed to get the
Avengers 4 trailer really soon but
here's the thing next week the week
after Thanksgiving is the one-year
anniversary of when they dropped the
Infinity Ward trailer they waited till
after the Thanksgiving holiday in Black
Friday to drop that what they did is it
was on a Tuesday so the Monday before
that they did it on Good Morning America
so Good Morning America tweeted this is
coming tomorrow and they just blasted it
all over their social media accounts so
when they were ready to drop the
infinity war trailer they let everybody
know there were no secrets like they
really wanted you to know that it was
gonna drop at a certain time on a
certain day so that you were all
prepared so just expect Marvel to do the
exact same thing however they didn't do
that till the day before the trailer
drop so don't expect them to talk about
the Avengers 4 trailer until the day
before they're actually ready to drop it
the other really big Avengers related
thing that's happening next week is the
Russos are doing a special screening of
infinity war will they'll do like a big
Q&A session so that's going to be
happening after the Tuesday that
potentially they would be dropping The
Avengers 4 trailer but the actual
screening that they're holding is
supposed to be for infinity warp but I
think the idea is is that if they do
decide to drop the trailer on the one
your anniversary of the infinity war
trailer than within a couple days of
that they have a special screening where
they do a QA answering all kinds of
questions about the Avengers movies
they'll be able to answer questions
about Avengers for stuff in the trailer
they'll probably do a lot of trolling
they probably won't give away any big
spoilers or anything like that
they'll be marketing it in a similar way
to the way that they dropped footage for
infinity war with a whole bunch of
scenes where they remove things where
they changed the CG so you weren't
really sure how many gems he had in his
gauntlet so just expect the same type of
treatment for the Avengers for footage
that'll be half the fun breaking down
the trailer as if it's legit like okay
this is happening then this is happening
here's a couple things going on in this
frame then after that trying to decide
how much of it is fake and won't make it
into the final cut of the film because
they bent over backwards to make that CG
version of the Hulk for the infinity war
trailer with no plans to put him in the
final cut of the film so just remember
that just don't freak out too much until
next week next week is really when you
need to be on alert but if I get any
news about them dropping footage before
then or anything like that of course I
will totally do a video but moving into
the official timeline this is part of a
book that they're getting ready to
release in the next couple of weeks so
that's why we have this official
timeline it wasn't like they just
tweeted it out randomly it does confirm
major continuity error in that eight
years later scene from spider-man
homecoming so we'll get to that on the
list but starting off we have 1943 to
1945 World War two Captain America the
First Avenger then they don't have it on
the list yet but Captain Marvel is 1995
so technically she's the next film in
the timeline after that 2010 we have
Iron Man 2011 Iron Man 2 The Incredible
Hulk
right after that Thor right after that
in the timeline just because anytime you
have movies that take place in the same
year usually it's a chronological
situation so if Iron Man is released
first in the year then that takes place
first in the timeline so Iron Man 2 then
the Incredible Hulk
then Thor all during 2011 the year after
that they team up in the Avengers then
Iron Man 3 picks up right after that
also during 2012 then the next year in
2013 we have Thor the dark world the
year after that in 2014 we have Captain
America the Winter Soldier at the
beginning of the year then guardians of
the galaxy takes place just a little bit
after that in the time
then remember guardians of the galaxy
vol 2 takes place in that same year just
a little while after the events of the
first film then that next year 2015 we
have the events of Avengers age of
Ultron then ant-man takes place right
after that 2016 we have Captain
America's Civil War at the beginning of
the year then spider-man homecoming
picks up a couple months after that
confirming that is four years later not
eight years later I'll explain why I
think they did eight years later because
that is a conscious choice on the
director in the producers part and they
do keep a running tally of the timeline
so I think they had a very specific
reason for making it eight years later
just hoping that nobody would call them
on the mistake then right after
spider-man homecoming during 2016 Doctor
Strange picks up he's still a surgeon he
gets in the car accident spends about a
year searching for a cure for his hands
trying to heal them then finds the
ancient one the movie ends during 2017
then a little while after the end of the
Doctor Strange movie Black Panther picks
up still during 2017 a little while
after the end of black panther the
events of thor ragnarok take place still
during 2017 then overlapping with that
is the beginning of infinity war when
Thanos shows up in the post-credits
scene in the sanctuary to ship to take
the Infinity stone from Loki that the
actual timeline for Avengers 4 jumps
around a lot it gets a little confusing
just because of all the plot mechanics
but early in the film is a relatively
short time jump into the future just to
show the things have changed at the end
of infinity war but the end of Avengers
4 takes place relatively close to the
end of infinity war because remember
they'll be fixing a lot of things so it
will be as if the snap has not happened
even though time does move forward a
little bit from the moment of the snap
but even though it sounds kind of
roundabout it's a way to explain how the
movie can end during 2018 even though
the infinity war snap happened during
2017 so a little time will pass because
spider-man far from home picks up just
minutes after the end of Avengers 4 and
that takes place during 2018 I know
people are confused about whether or not
it's a prequel but it takes place just a
little while after the end of the events
of Avengers 4 because it kicks off
everything in phase 4 Kevin Feige has
been hyping up spider-man far from home
like it's the beginning of all the new
stuff we're going to be doing but
getting back to that major continuity
error and spider-man homecoming eight
years later I think the reason the
director and the producers probably
landed on that number is because they
wanted to feel like a long time had
passed since the vulture had been
running his black market shatori weapons
operation and eight years is almost a
decade a long freakin time so if they
had been true to the actual timeline
battle of New York in 2012
spider-man homecoming in present day at
that time which was 2016 it would have
only been four years later and that just
feels kind of weak like only a couple of
years lame not enough time to have
passed for the vulture to get super rich
off all these weapons so you could see
why they were just trying to make
vulture feel like a much bigger deal in
a couple years isn't enough to do that
like it actually has to be a significant
amount of time the funny thing after
that to Kevin Feige is like yeah we
really try to avoid dating things in
movies just because it causes problems
like these but they do actually have a
document that they refer back to for
continuity purposes when it comes to
stuff like this so if one of the
directors that comes on for a new movie
has a question about when certain things
happen or one of the screenwriters needs
to know they just refer back to the
master document adjusted until this book
had been released they'd never revealed
it publicly but when I say they have a
master document of when everything has
happened in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe it's actually really detailed
so it tells you when people did things
not just when the movies came out so
like if there's a certain event that a
character refers to that happened a
couple of years ago they have it all
very carefully documented so a lot of
that will come into play during Avengers
four because of all the really twisty
stuff that they're doing with different
dimensions alternate versions of
characters looking into the past with
the be AR effing technology but also if
you guys didn't know they're doing the
Captain Marvel reshoots right now so
young Coulson young Nick Fury are all in
their makeup Captain Marvel is wearing
her green Kree Star Force uniform so it
seems like what they're shooting right
now is it's the early part of the movie
when she first comes back to Planet
Earth and first runs into Nick Fury and
Coulson while she's searching for all
those Scrolls before she starts to
remember her past there's a bunch of
spider-man far from home spider-man into
the spider-verse
Captain Marvel and Avenger stuff that's
going to be happening in the next couple
of weeks so I'll try to get through all
the videos as fast as possible
congratulations Randall Bork you're the
giveaway winner for my last big Marvel
video please email me on the about page
of my channel so I can get your contact
details click here to rewatch that new
Deadpool trailer and click here for that
Captain Marvel Avengers for prequels
story thank you so much for watching
everybody say awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]